all right guys so i wanted to share my
thoughts with you on this freddie gray
situation and the baltimore riots that
are happening literally as i speak uh
you know what this has made me realize
is that two things can be true at once
so there was an incredible miscarriage
of justice here in that there was no
justice what happened to freddie gray is
inexcusable and we have seen several
other examples in the last year
especially of this kind of thing the
black community feels like they're under
assault rightfully so
we definitely have we still have racial
problems in the country obviously
but there seems to be something systemic
uh going on with law enforcement and i
don't want to only blame law enforcement
because we also need law enforcement for
a lot of things but it seems that two
things can be true here because on one
hand we see people that are only
focusing on what happened to freddie and
not focusing on the rioters which is
awful also right and then there are
people that are only focusing on the
rioters and not focusing on freddie
which is what precipitated all this and
i think two things can be true at once
here so we do need to all as a country
our media our politicians us as citizens
need to think about more
about how
this type of stuff and this this race
what appears to be racial injustice
happening consistently why is this
happening we need to focus on that and
that at the same time we need to also
step up and acknowledge that when these
things happen that we still can't be
rioting and ransacking through our
cities and i know a lot of people would
argue well that's the only way you can
get the system to change i i personally
don't believe that i hope that's not how
it has to happen that to get change we
have to literally destroy stores i mean
people are destroying stores in their
own communities right now uh you know
destroying local cvs's and liquor stores
that that doesn't make anything change
that makes the system hit back harder so
there's a lot here but two things can be
true and we can focus on both of those
things making justice for freddie happen
and
and hopefully that stops future cases
like this and also stopping the rioting
which actually isn't helping people
think the media is driven by some agenda
i think the media is basically driven by
what people will watch and what people
click on so if a building is burning or
if a car is burning or there are people
attacking a cop car then yeah they are
going to focus on that because that's
what people watch and then it deflects
from actually what the more important
issue is which is getting justice for
freddie which it's too late for him to
get justice but getting justice for the
next freddy
so i think we all can do better and
that's what i'm trying to put out there
and that's what i hope you guys will try
to put out there as well